[Musik]
in der korona krise konkurrieren die
lobbys um die staatshilfen des bundes
eine davon ist die autoindustrie die mit
ihrem umsatz stark zur deutschen
wirtschaft beiträgt ihr argument die
verkaufszahlen von neuwagen brechen ein
hunderttausende menschen bangen um ihren
arbeitsplatz
die autolobby fordert eine abwrackprämie
um kaufanreize zu setzen
aber die umweltverbände sind dagegen die
lösung ist ein kompromiss mit einer
mehrwertsteuersenkung will die regierung
den kauf von benzinern ankurbeln
gleichzeitig fördert sie den ausbau der
elektromobilität
das zeigt wie lobbyismus auf die politik
einwirkt von lobbyismus spricht man wenn
interessengruppen versuchen politische
entscheidungen zu beeinflussen
diese gruppen können unternehmen
gewerkschaften verbände und ngo sein
sie vertreten die interessen von
arbeitnehmern und arbeitgebern
bestimmter berufsgruppen
industriezweigen sowie aus dem bereich
umwelt und tierschutz vor wichtigen
abstimmungen tauschen sich politiker und
interessenvertreter sogenannte
lobbyisten über branchenthemen und
gesetzesentwürfe aus
die lobbyisten sind experten auf ihrem
gebiet
sie gäben wichtige informationen an die
politik weiter
lobbyismus wird oft kritisiert
zum einen gibt es ein ungleichgewicht
von interessen finanz starke branchen
können häufig mehr druck auf die politik
ausüben als finanzschwache branchen
zum anderen finden viele treffen
zwischen politikern und lobbyisten im
geheimen statt
es mangelt an transparenz in deutschland
existiert noch kein lobbyregister dass
alle interessenvertreter dokumentiert
das soll sich nun ab september 2020
ändern
der bundestag hat entschieden eine
registrierungspflicht für alle lobbys
einzuführen
jetzt seid ihr gefragt findet ihr das
navi ist muss transparenter werden
sollte